bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors annick girardin
la ministre française de la mer dénonce
une mauvaise volonté de la part des
britanniques
est ce également votre sentiment
c'est tout à fait le sentiment de nos
professionnels puisque depuis neuf mois
maintenant nous travaillons à élaborer
des listes de navires et à prouver leur
antériorité dans ces eaux des îles anglo
normandes mais aussi des six à douze
mille qui sont situés plutôt au large de
des hauts de france et malgré ces
efforts
les résultats qui sont aujourd'hui
présentées sont bien évidemment
insuffisant puisque nous nous avons
prouvé il nous semble-t-il que tous les
navires qui figurait sur la liste avait
d antériorité et on comprend pas
pourquoi il n'y aurait qu'une partie de
ces navires qui se verrait attribuer ces
licences on a aussi le sentiment que
tout cela s'est fait aussi un peu de
manière à diviser et c'est justement
hier autour de la table que l'on a
réaffirmé la solidarité de l'ensemble
des régions et de l'ensemble des
pêcheurs il n'y a pas de raison que
certains auraient une licence et que les
autres ne l'aurait pas alors paris se
donne quinze jours pour étudier des
mesures de rétorsion à contre à londres
la france qui a également appelé à un
front commun européen face au
royaume-uni qu'est ce que vous attendez
concrètement de la part du gouvernement
français
alors ce que l'on attend du gouvernement
français c'est qu'ils puissent élaborer
ce fameux catalogue des mesures de dit
de rétorsion que l'on pourrait demander
à la commission européenne de mettre en
oeuvre rapidement
nous
considérons que finalement le l'accord
qui a été trouvé en décembre l'année
dernière est aujourd'hui
mise en oeuvre mais de façon inégale
puisque nos pêcheurs eux depuis le 1er
janvier n'obtiennent pas ce qu'ils
estiment être leur droit et justement
quelles sont les conséquences sur la
pêche française et sur les pêcheurs
est-ce que ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya une
grosse inquiétude de la part des de ces
pêcheurs qui sont aussi des chefs de
petites entreprises et qui n'ont pas de
visibilité c'est le cas notamment des
pêcheurs qui exercent leurs activités
dans les eaux des îles anglo-normandes
puisqu'il ya un régime de moder
d'autorisation provisoire qui sont
reportés de mois en mois et on arrive au
bout du bout et la fin du mois d'octobre
la perspective de ne pas obtenir ces
autorisations évidemment c'est anxiogène
pour toute cette population et puis vous
avez aussi parce que vous n'en parlez
pas dans votre reportage mais il ya
aussi des gens qui sont privés d'accès
dans les 6 à 12 milles plus au nord de
la france et pour eux c'est un manque à
gagner de 30 à 40 % parfois ce qui est
énorme
l'une concernant le timing aussi
puisqu'on sait que normalement c'est une
période qui est plutôt importante aussi
pour les pêcheurs de justement pouvoir
aller pêcher dans ses eaux là
oui tout est fait en fait nos pêcheurs
suivent le poisson le poisson se balade
tantôt il est dans les eaux de l'union
européenne tantôt il est dans les eaux
britanniques et ce sont souvent les
mêmes stocks d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour
ça que des navires britanniques viennent
aussi dans nos zones
donc du coup en fait que vous vous
souhaiter c'est que
quand on parlait de mesures de rétorsion
c'est que peut-être le navire
britannique ne viennent pas jusque dans
les eaux françaises
alors c'est pas tout à fait à ces
mesures que l'on pense la ministre a
donné quelques exemples hier de mesures
de rétorsion qui pourraient être
utilisés
alors il s'agit peut-être de renoncer à
accueillir des étudiants britanniques
chez nous il s'agit éventuellement de
2,2
de ne plus les fournir suivant des états
riches ils sont avantageux pour eux
notamment en matière de fourniture
d'énergie d'électricité par exemple
voilà les quelques quel exemple elle
nous a donné hier mais nous savons que
il y a une quantité
d'arguments en tout cas de levier
économique qui peuvent être utilisés
pour obtenir ce qu'on estime être notre
droit
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean le cam
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que zen directeur général du
comité national des pêches maritimes et
des élevages marins